How are the numbers for the astronaut training
program dismal i lost half my personnel in the
blip and half of those remaining have lost their
nerve the world's not the same as you left it
space is now full of unexpected threats always
was who whose protocol is this your mother's
she implemented guidelines in the event vanished
personnel ever returned my equipment registered
an extremely high level of cmbr that's
relic radiation dating back to the big bang
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my new Wandavision marvel fantastic four
easter eggs video some of you spotted a bunch of
them during Wandavision episode 4 so we'll break
it all down if you're brand new to my channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes i'm
doing videos for all the Wandavision episodes
all falcon winter soldier the loki episodes
everything that's coming this year it's going to
be crazy. Careful for spoilers if you have not
seen Wandavision episode four yet because we'll
be talking about everything that happens during
that there are obviously a lot of other fantastic
four easter eggs that have shown up recently in
marvel phase four trailers in the movies so i'll
talk about those at the end of the video too
but this is mostly just about the stuff that just
happened on Wandavision but big surprise or maybe
it shouldn't be a surprise because kevin feige
already confirmed Wandavision was setting up a
bunch of marvel phase 4 and future movie stuff
including doctor strange 2 spider-man 3 mutants
and what's happening with the new rebooted version
of the x-men and the mcu so i guess it shouldn't
also be a surprise that they're also using it to
set up the new fantastic four movie that was just
announced a little while ago being directed by
john watts who's currently directing spider-man
3 right now and finally i'm happy to announce a
film about one of the truly iconic marvel families
in fact marvel's first family fantastic four we're
working on a feature now and it will be directed
by the director of our recent spider-man films
john watts that's right the spider-man director
is going from the spider-man trilogy in the mcu
to the fantastic four movies assuming that there
will be sequels to that hopefully the first movie
does as well as we wanted to but like the video
that i attached to the beginning of this the
first big fantastic four easter egg scene is
when monica rambo is reporting back for duty at
the sword headquarters on earth talking to the
current director tyler hayward asking about their
astronaut training program and how she was part of
that program before avengers infinity war thanos's
infinity gauntlet snap and then the hulk's snap
and avengers end game blipping everyone back
so when this scene is happening it's been
three weeks since the end of avengers end game and
that's pretty much when the entire wanda vision
series takes place so we're literally right after
the events of avengers end game and tyler hayward
says that half of the astronauts that they had
in training were snapped and just came back
are starting to trickle in and the other half who
didn't get snapped completely lost their nerve and
quit the program during the five-year time jump
between infinity war and endgame so that's why
he's saying that sword pivoted from being more
of a shield version of nasa to being more about
sentient weapons artificial intelligence and
unmanned space missions the threads from outer
space that he mentions is mostly referenced to
thanos in the infinity gauntlet but it's also
foreshadowing for the celestials which we'll see
more of during the eternals movie hopefully later
this year please marvel don't delay your movies
anymore then you have beings like galactus when
we eventually do get the new fantastic four movies
monica rambeau then follows up by saying that there
are also friends in outer space that's a reference
to people like the asgardians thor the other side
of the galactus coin characters like the silver
surfer who are friends to the marvel characters
then they talk about special protocols that
they have at sword for what to do when their
astronauts return or if they return from
being lost in accidents and missions like
the snap or anything else that could possibly
go horribly wrong on their missions then later
when they're monitoring scarlet witch's house of m
alternate reality darcy starts talking about cmbr
they mentioned it several times during the episode
cosmic microwave background radiation the same
type of cosmic energy that made up the energy of
the big bang when the universe was first created
so that's a reference to a couple things including
fantastic four stuff on the surface level it's
a reference to scarlet witch's reality warping
powers from the comics it's a way of explaining
on the show how she's creating and changing
things out of nothing like how she created
her two children who are mutants billy and tommy
wicken and speed from the comics because vision
would normally be incapable of fathering children
the old-fashioned way but the whole concept
of cosmic radiation is also how the fantastic
four got their powers in the comics they were
astronauts on a science mission in space studying
cosmic radiation waves when they were hit by one
mutating their dna giving them their powers my
research suggests that exposure to a high-energy
cosmic storm born on solar wind might have
triggered the evolution of early planetary life
in six weeks another cloud with the same
elemental profile will pass earth's orbit
a study conducted in space could fundamentally
advance our knowledge about the structure of the
human genome cure countless diseases extend human
life give kids a chance to live longer stronger so
you have the sword space agency which is training
astronauts to face threats from cosmic marvel
characters like galactus the celestials you have
nick fury's sword space station that he built with
the scrolls then on the other side you have high
levels of cosmic radiation present after avengers
end game and a bunch of missing astronauts that
are slowly starting to show up after the movie
and sword trying to rebuild their astronaut
program looking for new candidates so most of you
probably came to the same conclusion after some of
these scenes in Wandavision episode 4 that the new
mcu fantastic four will come from sword like they
may have already been part of the sword astronaut
training program before the events of avengers
infinity war maybe they were snapped and blit back
and up to this point the reason why we haven't met
or heard about reed richards or the others is that
before avengers end game the blip and hopefully
a timely accident with cosmic radiation while
they're in space they were just normal astronaut
trainees normal scientists that you wouldn't have
thought twice about nothing really special about
them other than maybe that they were just rank
and file sword agents like astronaut versions
of regular shield agents no big deal in their
origin in the mcu will be tied to Wandavision
and how it sets up mutants in marvel phase four
even though technically the fantastic four aren't
mutants there's something called mutates which is
a little bit different but all happening through
this conceit of scarlet witch manipulating
cosmic radiation and that just going off the
rails like darcy also says the field that she's
generating is contained to westview this town but
just for now like they think that it might expand
eventually that's the big threat that eventually
might cover the earth and start warping reality
all over the planet there are a lot of other
fantastic four easter eggs we've seen recently
during the loki trailer ant-man 3 and even
during spider-man far from home and i mean
you know the same director is doing the fantastic
four movies so no surprise that he'd also tease
fantastic four stuff during the spider-man movies
even though it seems like they're already doing
full-blown spider-verse during spider-man 3 i
wouldn't be surprised if there are also some
more fantastic four easter eggs in the background
as well i've already talked about the easter egg
during spider-man far from home it's all about
the construction sign at the end of the movie
when he swings down the sign says one two three
then the question mark where the four should be
all in different colors and it reads we
can't wait to show you what comes next
it's a reference to a couple different things
to marvel phase 4 in general like kevin feige
is winking behind the camera saying we at
marvel can't wait to show you marvel phase 4
what's coming next in terms of the movies in
the disney plus series but also the numbers
are a reference to the fantastic four the colors
correspond to all their different powers and the
reason why the 4 is invisible is because it's
referencing the invisible woman the other even
more recent easter eggs in the loki trailer and
ant-man 3 are both for the same thing technically
it's for king the conqueror whose real name is
nathaniel richards he's a distant descendant
many many times removed from a thousand years
in the future of reed richards he's going to be
played by jonathan majors during ant-man 3. he's
going to be the main villain of that movie and
he'll be teased during the loki's series he's a
time travel villain in the time variance authority
which we see during the loki series is all about
clocking time travel villains they haven't started
casting for the fantastic four movie yet they
haven't announced any actors even though john
krasinski has been posting all kinds of teasers
like oh it'd be so amazing to do this but just
based on all the announcements so far and what the
timeline of the marvel phase 4 movies is they'll
probably wind up releasing the new fantastic four
movie sometime between spring and summer of 2023
we will continue to see more fantastic four easter
eggs before then in the disney plus series in the
upcoming movies so of course i'll do videos for
all those when we start spotting them but if you
have spotted any other big fantastic four easter
eggs or references that i didn't mention in this
video just write them below in the comments in my
Wandavision episode 5 video we'll post this friday
and there's going to be some special spider-man
3 announcements happening thursday tom holland
is doing something special so of course i'll do a
video for that too super bowl 2021 is also coming
up this weekend so there might be some marvel
super bowl trailers for the upcoming disney
plus series maybe the movies i don't know if
we're going to be seeing a shang chi trailer or
another black widow trailer hopefully there'll
be another falcon in winter soldier trailer
not really expecting a full-blown spider-man
3 trailer so i wouldn't hold your breath on
that but hopefully there'll be a venom 2 trailer
whatever kind of footage they wind up releasing
or anything special on the side even if it's not
during the actual super bowl i'll be doing videos
for that stuff so no worries any big trailer
videos but everyone click here for my brand new
Wandavision episode 5 trailer video and click here
for that brand new thor 4 love and thunder first
look thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you in the next video!